neil sperling
that's me thanks for coming on the show
proud and pleased to be here it's our
honor
and i'm very grateful to tristan tyler
blake for
introducing us making this happen well
the universe chooses things for us and
here we are
yeah we're co-creators we do
yeah sometimes we're even conscious of
it
okay actually that was a straight line
so i'm glad i'm bringing you to
a level of of humor and enjoyment so
early in our conversation
yeah in any event how can i provide you
with excellent services yeah
well likewise in return all right
yeah yeah oh i know where that could go
neil yes super connecting
systematizing genius very very important
topics that are
near and dear to my heart genius yeah
well i appreciate that uh
description that you've given of me have
you been drinking this evening
any of that no thank you very much i'm
very flattered
i'm looking forward to unpacking this i
want to start with your journey
who were you growing up what was who
were you growing up
who was who was i growing up who were
you growing up i thought you were saying
who was i growing
up i misheard that but see that's
actually
a really good segue because you know i
think
part of my gift
is that i listen and hear things
differently than people traditionally do
there's a lot of word play going on in
my brain and i
discovered that pretty early on
who was i growing up i i frankly i've
shared this with other people and other
interviews but i think i was pretty much
a misfit
i like that word a lot right because i
think a lot of people can identify
if you haven't found your passion your
purpose or your place
in the world or what you want to do you
do feel like that and so
i think a lot of people can identify
with that and
and i i believe i was one of the world's
greatest misfits because
i had a lot of interest in curiosity in
so many areas
and what i discovered is is that i was
good at a lot of things
but i wasn't great at a lot of things
and i think it's a frustration for a lot
of people
to find where their greatness lies and i
do believe every one of us
every one of us is put on this earth for
a reason
and it is to discover our passion our
purpose
and through that this journey where we
ask questions and
try to figure out where we fit that we
become self-actualized
yes and when we're self-actualized we're
in the zone
and we're happy and we're content and
we're serving our purpose which is
partly not only to serve ourselves but
to serve one another
and if you do that often enough my own
personal
feeling about it is is that eventually
if you do it right
or if you believe in reincarnation and
you get to come back and keep doing it
more often and better you get to
graduate yeah
yeah my personal belief being that when
you graduate
you have an understanding that allows
you
a sensitivity and empathy with other
people that you've been
interacting with that
when you're eventually going home or as
some people say
you know when you go to die if you were
to
find heaven wouldn't it be the ultimate
definition of heaven
if everyone understood how to get along
so for me the journey as you said that's
the key word that i spark to
is like growing up i think we're all in
a process of growing up when we come to
this world
none of us really have clarity we don't
have clearly about ourselves we don't
have clarity about what we're supposed
to do
and the journey becomes the answer
yes so i don't know if i answered your
question beautiful but
beautifully yeah so many good parts to
play off there doing a lot of
things well but not being great at any
of them is a common theme of
polymaths people that have learned much
a lot across a lot of different fields
and it makes them able to see
connections between ideas and people
that other people can't see
my hannity cap became my blessing
because i
i find i can relate to what you just
shared
that curiosity led me to study many many
many subjects
and attempting to master them i wasn't
as good as i wanted to be but
in growing up i think around 15 i've
talked about this elsewhere as well
i was given a test for puzzles
and i didn't even know what it was
measuring but
it was apparently measuring my ability
to do abstract reasoning predictive
modeling you know when you see these
shapes and which would
connect up with each other in your most
optimal sense
it was a breeze for me and i didn't
realize that that was probably my gift
but
i was able to see pretty instantly how
things fit together
how people fit together uh how
systems fit together just connecting the
puzzles
connecting the dots and i didn't know
you could do anything with that i didn't
know you could make a career
out of it but it gave me clarity at that
point that i
wasn't necessarily a misfit that was one
thing i was apparently
i'll say great at because when i
tested the first time i got 100 score
and they thought they wanted to come
back and ask me the question
um we'd like to test you again
and i said why and i said well we want
to make sure we didn't make a mistake
and so when i took the test a second
time i scored another 100 percent
so i didn't again know what exactly that
could lead me into but eventually
i built a career into solving problems
and challenges
and connecting with people
in ways that allow me to practice my
gift
and i guess the theme of that is is that
no one should ever give up
because we always doubt ourselves we're
not sure we don't have the clarity
but sometimes the clarity can find us
yeah
my my take on some of the
metaphysics of the soul coming into the
vehicle on the planet
is aligned with what you say
in many ways in the sense of there's a
veil
for the soul in the vehicle and that
what happens is over time the veil
in two ways becomes pierced
one of the ways is through
self-actualization which you described
which is when
the the in the soul becomes more
sovereign it becomes more aligned with
its higher purpose a higher gift or
higher calling of their basic needs are
met
and so they're able to pursue that that
higher calling at a deeper level where
they become in service to not only
themselves
but to others in an economic nash
equilibrium style
and then on another side of the self
actualization is what is usually termed
in spiritual
mystic traditions as self-realization
and i think that psychology and
a lot of the other sort of very
more
societal structures exist to accelerate
self-actualization but not very many
exist for self-realization and in the
sense of
self-realization it's consciousness
awakening to its own nature
what the nature of itself is and what
the nature of these realities
are and that is usually associated with
things around
concepts like infinity or eternity or
love and compassion and peace and joy
and bliss
and things like this the highest
possible morality the highest possible
ethics
and self-actualization doesn't always
also include
that at the same time and so i think
those two are very important in
systematizing genius so that
the veil is not only pierced for
those that come with the intent to
actualize
gifts but at the same time it's to
realize
the nature of being itself at the same
time
when listening to you i was just
visualizing
the yin needs the yang needs it
much like quantum entanglement
where you have these disparate particles
but they find each other and they get
entangled
and it's interesting to contemplate
because
spiritual meets material in a sense and
yes when they combine you truly are what
you were meant to be
and that is the essence i would say
of what is the most profound thing for
civilization to wake up to
is that you have a big synthesis that
needs to happen
between what we could say is like you
described a physicalism and a
spirituality
and that we need to in a sense
like we talk about in high level
perception chapter 7 the sorting
algorithm we need to drain the dirty
bath water
from both of them and we need to uplift
the baby
of physicalism and the beauty of that
accelerating meeting the basic needs of
people around the planet
but also the baby of spirituality that
is these
as mirch eliade says it's these
hierophanies it's the manifestation of
the divine
and you bring these two things together
marry them into one
and that's when you have a truly
anchored
civilization in what can be the maximum
abundant truth
prosperity i want to ask you a question
about what
you were explaining to us along this
journey of yours you
identified okay you're a pattern
recognition
an abstract reasoning a predictive
modeling style
soul that's really high level at that
and that that's giving
that's one of the highest signs of
intelligence
that we've been able to identify thus
far and it's a very common
theme of people that come on the program
and so from there
you said that you began doing these
fitting solutions to problems what were
some of those that you began
doing the first was just working on
myself i felt like such a misfit and i
couldn't
figure out what slot i belong in or
should be in
that i started to think about okay so
what am i good at
and solving puzzles and problems seemed
to be
a talent that i had and so in looking
that
you know i realized that you know there
there's a process to this
and i noticed there's structures to
successful people and one of the
structures they fell into consistently
was
they seemed to be systems thinkers they
were able to figure out
there's a system and in fact now when i
look at things i've gotten in a groove
where i just look at every subject as a
system in disguise
and it could even be abstractions like
love or honesty
there's a system to figuring out if
someone's being honest with you
if someone's then ultimately the
compatible partner for you
and and so it's breaking the system down
on its elements
and the more that you can identify the
more awareness you have and the more
discriminating you can be to project
forward whether you have that right
system that will work for you um
what landed me on stage one of my big
breakthrough speeches was
i was just having a casual conversation
with someone who was an event
coordinator
and he asked me about my day and i said
you know i
think i've stumbled onto something
interesting about honesty and how to
identify
if someone's being really honest which
is a critical thing in business because
if you can't trust people how can you do
business with them
and on a personal level if you can't
trust your
mate or your friend you know
how can you continue a relationship with
them and so i broke it down into
elements i
i thought about it for a number of days
and i said there's four things i
identified and that was with honesty
someone has to have good judgment
because if they don't you can't
trust them you can't trust their
judgment but even if they have that and
they have the obvious thing that you're
looking for which is character
they don't have the good judgment can
you trust them
if they have good judgment and good
character
but they don't have good habits and
they're not dependable they don't show
up on time they don't do what they say
can you trust them
and even if you had all three of those
if they had
the other element that i identified
which is
a lack of uh temperament and they're
bipolar
or they're narcissistic or they're
sociopathic can you trust them
so when you start thinking about that i
looked at it like the four corners of
the person like people look at four
corners of a contract
and i said gee you know if i could
identify
and took take some time with each person
that i meet
to consistently determine in each of
those areas that they have consistent
qualities that are high ranking they're
a keeper
anyway that so apparently impressed them
it landed me on stage to share that
but i looked at it as a system and it's
the same
with anything any subject you know now i
i have a rhythm to this i i look at
what is the system what are the elements
in the system
and then what is the sequence a lot of
people get tripped up on that
in business where they think they've got
the system but they're at step three and
they're not really clear about step one
again it all goes back to clarity
so ultimately i found coming out of my
misfittedness
that the joy that i get is providing the
clarity
by taking people through the process to
get that clarity by
achieving an understanding of what the
system is really comprised of
what the sequence is to have the optimal
result
and by accelerating that getting the
success
and so now i've applied that as a result
of trying to solve my own problem which
should allow me some clarity to see how
i can
help support other people
one of the keys that you began
sharing with us that has really
resonated with me
a lot is this style of thinking that i
learned from ken wilbur around hollar
keys
and that it seems like things are in
fact hollands inside of each other
and that those can be viewed as systems
that the the cell is a system inside of
your body
and that you are a system your entire
body of 30 plus trillion cells is a
system
then you are an individual inside of a
civilization which is a system
yeah and so that's stylish everything is
scalable you know
we can get into a really esoteric
metaphysical conversation but
recently i've been studying a lot about
uh the human brain
as a system and we've talked about this
and then
the universe as a system and the
fascinating things that scientists are
just now identifying that
if you take the slice of a brain cell of
a mouse
and you overlay it of a slice of a photo
that hubble has composited
from all the many photos has taken of
the universe
they're virtually identical identical in
the filaments that run through them
which
if you look at it the brain is comprised
chiefly of water
and space they're now identifying is
largely dark matter and through these
filaments that run through each
you know you start to wonder about the
connections of like cosmic consciousness
when people pray
and they have a you know a spiritual
experience
there's a lot of overlays that are going
on there that
because you know i tend to have an
associated brain and see
how the connections run i thought it was
fascinating just reading the other night
that when the big bang took place they
believed that there was about 11
dimensions that collapsed into what we
can experience through our limited
senses today
and then through these experiments they
were just recently doing
the news just came out the human brain
is so complex with the neurons
of the network of neurons just like we
have a network of stars in the universe
that the numbers are even similar number
of stars they've identified with the
number of neurons we have in our brain
that the human brain apparently is so
complex
it can perceive in 11 dimensions not
nine
not ten not 12 but 11.
and so that interconnectivity is is kind
of fascinating to me
because it really implies that systems
are interoperating but they're also
growing in scale
yeah and some of the other aspects that
i found fascinating were the fibonacci
sequence which operates on the same wave
because it starts at a micro level
and as you continue to scale up even as
you mentioned like the human body
your pinky is a uh i think the scale for
the
fibonacci sequence the golden ratio is
1.618 that's right
and if i'm not mistaken and correct me
if i'm wrong
but your pinky that ratio to the
length of your arm to the length of your
entire body
is 1.618 i was fascinated to learn at
the macro level
that the ratio of the moon to the center
of the
earth 1.618 the ratio of the planets
that are lined throughout our solar
system
separate from each other 1.618
and it goes on and on the spiral
galaxies
the curve of that galaxy 1.618
so there are ratios in nature
and uh in concepts and subjects
and and when you start comparing these
and learning there's a
there's a structure and order of the
universe and the beauty and discovering
of that is how you can turn that
back and apply it to your life and
consequently live
a life in the golden ratio yeah where
it's becomes a beautiful life where
you're combining spirituality
your intellect uh your emotions
and fusing them together in the most
optimal sense you're self-actualized
and then consequently you don't really
have a lack of clarity anymore
yep
to leverage the
insatiable curiosity for the patterns
that exist and i love the one that you
take us to because there are these
neural networks in the brain and then
these
appear as neurons as well humans in the
civilizational brain and then
the universe scale brain that we
discussed a moment ago
and then there's all of the fibonacci
golden ratio
patterns that exist around us and we
talk about these hierarchical levels
that exist
and when one begins to fully grasp
those and begin to attempt to
figure out if i feel like my
north star is in the field of
bioengineering
i must know the fundamental hierarchical
unit of a cell
i must know it very very well
but there's a power law distribution
around the
couple tail end things
to know about the cell and to know about
things like crispr cast 9
in order for you to become the vast
majority proficient in the field of
bioengineering
and that's the classic pareto principle
20 of things you learn are going to give
you 80
of knowledge in the field and so to
figure that out
for every single field right we have the
young we're in los
angeles there's many young artists here
that are passionate about
acting that are passionate about about
music
you just that one just met some yes
right that's right
and so this there's a
there's a systemic way to
make yourself the most possible uncommon
people that have ever lived
and to truly realize that that is a
possibility for
yours for for your potential and
then to help people along the way when
we see the patterns
to help them see the patterns to help
them achieve themselves towards their
stars more efficiently
is that in essence i've i've talked
about this and
to amplify on it you know it's
fascinating because
um i when i took that test
i also took another test i guess with
mensa and i'm not shy about saying i
felt three points short of genius
i'm not a genius but it it was troubling
to me
that i couldn't be one if i wanted to be
one
and so i figured out how could i be one
if if i could how could i be smarter
than what
the standard test told me in this
particular aspect of things
academic wise versus creative wise
and what i realize is it's always the
same procedure you want to start with
the goal
and reverse engineer and figure out
because these structures and these
systems there's
an interoperability of scale that
how do you get there so there's examples
of people and i started studying
the great masters einstein edison um
da vinci more recently steve jobs elon
musk
what they had in common is can you learn
genius or
are you just born a genius and when the
exciting thing for me after spending
many many years studying this is i truly
believe that anyone
can discover their genius within and we
all have that
it's just the lack of clarity of how to
identify it and access it
so for me what i discovered
was that the great geniuses that
i just mentioned all pretty much saw
things as systems
and they came at it from slightly
different directions because that's the
beauty
of the diversity that we have but they
all met at the same intersection
in terms of how they accessed and
processed this so
one of the things i'm looking forward to
is now
providing that opportunity to other
people to access their own genius
by uncovering the system and the
sequence
to solve literally any subject
that they're confronting and you know
what that does
it provides confidence which is
something i lacked being a misfit
so it's kind of a beautiful way of how
it all came full circle for me
but it's also a great comfort to know
that people
who are striving for whatever they are
in clarity
and their personal life their
professional life
their business life there are shortcuts
to clarity and and so i don't know if
i'm directly answering your question but
that's what it triggered in me
because it's really about what i
discovered as a misfit i didn't
understand
what my passion or my purpose was but
now it's all aligned
in that and that same opportunity
can be accessible to anyone yes
shortcuts shortcuts to clarity yeah
that's beautiful and it's
likely one of the most important things
that we can do
as a society is enable people to see
beyond that veil that consciousness has
around its self-actualization
realization
with those shortcuts to pierce that veil
the frustration i find is that
a vast majority of people think
transactionally and in the moment
and it's basically the survival
component you know they have to think
about food on the table they have to
think about what time their wife is
expecting them home and all these things
where
we're just trying to get through the day
and solve the basic necessities
but when you can figure out these things
that allow you to get beyond the basic
necessities just like in maslov's
hierarchies of needs you realize
that you can spend more time
focusing on this development inner
development
that allows you to um really contribute
uh beyond just thinking about today
so i've realized that a lot of people
that i
deal with in the world are transactional
for that reason
but at the same time those who are more
relationship-oriented can see the
relationships
between the puzzle pieces and and what
they're looking to do and their goals
generally can see down the chess board a
little further
and consequently are able to
be more effective in the world because
they're not just thinking in the moment
they're not thinking about the
transaction but they're seeing that
the fountain is really the relationship
and the glass of water the transaction
or the deal of the moment or whatever
they have to address in their personal
life
is the glass of water and so when you
refocus
on the fountain that feeds the glass of
water that's right
essentially you have you know it's a
kind of a very liberating
moment when you see that when you can
adjust your thinking in that way
you can find inner peace and as well as
contributed to
others peace yep yep
one of the things that i probably i love
that analogy that that one's extremely
rich and hopefully it can
assist people in seeing that that
fountain is that
in that sense it's that source of
healing that source of
richness that source of love that source
of compassion that source of helping
others with their goals
all this type of stuff rather than the
transactional glass of water that's a
great one
one where
i feel a strong synthesis between what
you're saying right now
and what show we just did with tristan a
moment ago
was where we were demoing tristan's
technology that he's developed like his
stem notebook
and how fascinating it is that as you
sort of
enter into these different fields
on this massive landscape
that there is a very structured way
to when you click artificial
intelligence or you click
blockchains and cryptocurrencies when
you click into these different
fields what happens is you get the
population of the core
concepts in that field
and then we just go through the process
of training ourselves it
it took me five years to learn what the
word recursion meant
and i had to continue coming back and
revisiting it and
i think one of the reasons why is
because there are very few
storytellers that teach about a concept
like recursion when the procedure calls
on itself nobody is saying that
the seed of a tree the acorn undergoes
recursion when it makes the oak tree and
it drops more
acorns but your challenge in that was
probably
your gift to others when you understood
it better is that you could share it and
pay it forward right
so that's probably i'm going to intuit
is one of the aspects of reasons why
you're on the earth
that's right and you're doing it here
yeah that's it
the the concept itself is important to
land
in embodied
but the more beautiful thing is when the
concept becomes so
explained like i'm five simplified and
this is why
the genius johan wolfgang von guerte
said that the perfect educational
lecture belongs in the artist's sphere
of work
and so i'm obsessed with trying to
simplify these
complex concepts about a.i and about
decentralization and about neuroscience
geniuses and making things
things simple yeah reducing everything
to its simplest level of complexity
the uh one of the archetypes that i
point to is einstein when he came up
with e equals m mc square now there's
four simple little characters
to explain explain an extremely complex
subject that most people still are fuzzy
about
but by reducing it to its simplest level
complexity
it makes it more manageable to digest
and and synthesize and and understand
so i think really what genius is is just
being able to do that and i don't know
that i'm a genius
and again when i tested uh you know on
the academic side of the
actually this would be a good time to
bring this up last time you said this
this is really important
those that are really good at
the abstract reasoning and the pattern
identification
even if they are quote
genius on the iq in that sense
i would actually prefer to be friends
with
and prefer to civilization also prefers
this as well
is the people that are maybe not as
strong
on the patterns but that actually
know how to create portals
into the rest of the world that then
teach people about if you can't
explain like i'm five if you can't
form the most complex concepts into art
that then awakens people to the higher
levels of perception
your genius is almost completely
irrelevant it only serves
just you sitting on some mountain top or
putting sitting inside of some loan
office not
actually able to and this is why a lot
of genius needed
translators as well your obstacles or
your opportunities just like what you
wrestle with for five years
everyone has obstacles you might want to
become a great actor
or a great ball player the
information is out there and we can
learn from others but
i think the genius is in systematizing
what we learn in ways that simplify
and we can call on to repeat to practice
and as a result get better at what we do
and it applies across the board in every
field in
all forms of communication and in all
forms of interaction because everything
is in relationship to each other
so people who can really appreciate
what relationships are not just in the
abstract sense of
you and me is in a relationship but
everything physically spiritually
intellectually is in a relationship to
one another
and and so to really reduce each of
these as subjects
to their simplest level allows us the
access and the clarity to be effective
yep now given the fact that
we're here in los angeles
a
current phenomenon that's occurring is
that there is a
tendency for those that are younger in
the millennial
or the generation z or the generation
alpha
groups to have a
desire to want to become an influencer
on the internet
and so there's a systematized process
in order to most effectively
create mimetics as richard dawkins
would say and in doing so when you
create these units of cultural
information transfer
what occurs is you can package together
some of
civilization's most profound wisdom in
these
instagram tv stories or little tick
tocks
or five 10-minute 15-minute youtube
videos maybe these longer-form podcasts
documentaries anthologies animations all
different types of packaging
as the golgi apparatus would do in the
cell all these different ways to package
together
the mimetics into
a vesicle that then goes out and ends up
impacting
other people's awareness around the
world and now you have the ability to
impact four billion
people that are connected on the actual
technology infrastructure
so this is probably a very relatable one
in los angeles and in entertainment
beyond la because there are lots of kids
growing up around the world that are
becoming more and more interested
in this style of systematizing
themselves to become an influencer
do you see that as something that is
not only able to be systematized in the
way that i
described it is there anything that
can't be systematized
i honestly don't believe so anymore i i
know that
uh after i spoke on stage in that
transformative
uh opportunity that i was given i had 20
people
sign up just for a session with me for
an hour
and they had incredibly complex problems
and i was really thinking you know i may
be suffering from imposter syndrome
because
i they were so diverse and like what if
i can't answer their questions
i fall on my face or they want their
money back but
i got through 20 through 20 and they
were all like glowing and
uh raving about my ability to take them
through this journey
i spent a half an hour at the first star
just actively listening
and as i was listening i was
systematizing my brain the pieces that
they were missing or the clarity and
then the next half hour i was just
stream of consciousness where they had a
race to keep up with me but it went from
a woman who wondered why
she had been sexually harassed on the
police force to somebody who had
a uh a business that was freight
forwarding and
need to come up with four million
dollars by tomorrow
where his shareholder funder would shut
him down
and you think those would have nothing
to do with each other and they were
disparate subjects but they were really
systems in disguise that hadn't been
perfected to the degree they could be
and so i'm a great believer that yeah
there
there is an approach here that can work
for literally anyone and you and i
talked about it
i think the other night where um i'm
thinking about
now launching some masterminds where i
can help people
with these different areas of their life
to fully become
not only self-actualized but
self-realized
and we need to talk about that more yes
but essentially the idea is there's ways
to
perfect your iq because there's a system
inside that that you don't necessarily
have to be born with
you don't necessarily have to have the
dna but
the the access to how that works and
then the second part is having a good eq
yeah and having a high eq allows you the
empathy
to relate to people that they're if no
matter how high
your iq is if they can't relate and
enjoy the experience
they're they're going to tune out and
then having the high eq
is still insufficient because you have
to have a high sq which is a spiritual
quotient right
and and you need to really have a sense
a anchored sense of you know what
what's real and what's important and and
how to
deduce that and a calmness and a
foundation that that provides
and when you put all that together i
think you're self-actualized and
self-realized and then
then you can learn technique because
most people get it wrong they want to
learn the technique first and put the
roof up
but if you don't have a strong
foundation the house can't stand as
sturdy as it could otherwise
so with that there's various techniques
you know there's podcasts there's
uh using email there's that's all whole
cloth stuff
but you can't really become an
influencer
unless you understand these really
important foundational pieces that allow
people to trust you
yeah and they can intuit that and once
they do
and you're authentic and you can shed
all of these
affectations of you know being salesy
and
you know all the marketing lingo yeah um
when they trust you they can take in the
information
and i truly believe i can show people
ways to become literally a
highest level servant influencer
yes in their field that will attract
people rather than having to sell them
that's right right
they they come to you they they want to
be in your orbit
and and so i think that's the beauty of
most beautiful and
uh purest form of influence
i love the example of all of the
different
people that come to you because
you share with them the way that you've
identified the patterns
in how to systematize genius across
different fields
including the not only iq but also
in emotional intelligence how to teach
people how to drop
in to another person you can communicate
but not connect
you can network that's right and maybe
communicate and you can
communicate and network but still it
really happens in the connection
and the ironic thing for me is i don't
know how i exactly turn this all into a
career but
i'm not on any social media because i
know i'd be overwhelmed because i
through my own private network
people are always coming to me and
people have asked like what is your
business model and i just say you know i
wake up in the morning and i wait for
the phone to ring
and it's a beautiful thing because it's
not like you're having to constantly
advertise and
and come up with something more clever
in terms of your
your branding or your you know your your
marketing statement
it's people seek you out because they
feel comfortable
and they feel like you're going to treat
them with honesty
and that you're service oriented and
those are really some of the basic
secrets like i said i just reduce it to
its simplest level of complexity it's
not that complicated
yeah i loved how you focused on trust
in the beginning and how you're bringing
it back right now because
and it's also super interesting that
when people
undergo processes of self-realization
usually what occurs is that
their consciousness no longer
is tied to some sort of belief about
their ego
that it moves away from a
service to self only self-dealing
feeling process to a
as the great child and adult
psychologists of our time have
identified in spiritual leaders
that there is a sort of
systematized process that consciousness
undergoes to evolve from
egotistical to then social
and then ethno and then world and then
eventually you get into some stuff like
the trans-personal
and the non-dual and potentially the
symphonic
idea that we've been sharing on the
program quite a bit
and so when somebody experiences
something like a non-dual state of
awareness then there is no longer
that style of service to self ego
dynamic which then creates the trust
it creates the authenticity that's where
self-realization
can play a massive role in people
actualizing
their fullest gifts i remember when i
so long often felt like a misfit growing
up
i was self-conscious uh when i
managed to shed the self-consciousness
and start thinking about other people
and being more of a servant versus
serving myself which is a place we all
start from because we have that
that need to put food on the table and
take care of you know all the things
that we need to take care of in life
uh things opened up for me and i think i
shared with you the story earlier when
my parents
both died not having any brothers or
sisters
and my mom asked me the question on her
deathbed what was it all for
and i couldn't answer that question it
tore me up inside so i spent five years
writing
world leaders to understand
you know what is essentially the secret
people who had accomplished great things
that other people only aspire to achieve
in all fields
and the two fascinating recurring themes
that came back
out of that five-year project were that
we need to figure out how to put
each other first instead of ourself
first
and the second thing that we need to do
is have the discipline
to maintain that ability to continue to
think that way because it's not easy to
think that way
and if we can do that we may even have a
shot at making it to the 22nd century
that's right so so many people focus on
the fact that
we have nuclear powers we have all this
outward manifestation of our ability to
destroy or compromise one another
there's environmental degradation these
are all outer manifestations of who we
are in our inner space
but if in our inner space we understand
that we're all interconnected
and we're all in a relationship and how
i
impact you or how you impact me
impacts the final end game
then if we can change and shift that
consciousness
and start thinking more along those
lines we may have a shot
at continuing because right now we're in
a lot of trouble
so it's really not that complicated
because that i think also reduces that
subject to its simplest level of
complexity
yes yes it's
profound how these
seemingly traumatic experiences
is one of the most common archetypes of
the
leaders that we've had the opportunity
to sit down with on the program and it's
also one of the most common archetypes
of the hundreds of thousands of people
that psychoanalysts have studied
is the trauma to treasure archetype so
you have this profound experience with
your mother that then
catalyzes and search for
what is this all about and how can we
maximize human potential
and the answer the pattern from the
leaders is that
it must go in that service to other
dynamic rather than that service the
self dynamic the wii rather than the me
but at the same time that's not to
pathologize it and create some sort of a
dynamic where you
absolutely deteriorate your own vehicle
just always in service to to the wii
but then on the second step is to
basically discipline
ourselves continuously over time to be
in that nash equilibrium where every
decision that we make as a sovereign
individual
is simultaneously benefiting the
collective
balance yeah right and so things have to
be
in balance for them to be their optimal
most effectiveness
so if it's out of balance and we're more
focused on ourself
and it goes to the times today you know
we're in a very sad time of divisiveness
and i believe because we're not in
balance and why are we not in balance
because
we're looking for the faults in others
rather than addressing ourselves first
to build a more stable foundation that
allows us to be less judgmental because
as even
christ said you know uh judge not lest
he be judged
and we're forgetting basic simplicities
that have just been repackaged through
time
and it's a shame because right now you
know we look for the differences rather
than the commonalities
i'm very worried about the united states
because we're supposed to be the united
states
and instead we're falling further apart
and giving aid and comfort to our
enemies who are our adversaries who are
enjoying it and democracy
is something that's critically important
because we can't even have these
discussions without the structure and
the framework of a democracy
and and so i think people are losing
sight
of what they need to get back to in the
simplest form
which is respect and
patience and all those basic
virtues that we were taught in school
that we when we've grown up here we've
lost and
forgotten about but we need to get back
to
if again we're going to make it yeah so
that's my personal soapbox but i'm i'm
really passionate about
helping people discover that just
because somebody else appears to be a
misfit to you
doesn't mean that they can't improve or
that you can
improve and that you consequently can
improve the relationship
to get beyond that yep
within the
experience that you were telling me
about where you had the opportunity to
realize you came up with this profound
and this is one of those self-realizing
moments
when you came up with this important
embodied realization
that the orangutan is 97
genetically similar to the human and yet
we identify the three percent genetic
difference as the most important thing
to focus our attention on
and the same thing that i wrote in
chapter 9 on consciousness and
high-level perception
where if we apply calculus to
consciousness we can begin perceiving
things like the integral
the integration of the infinitesimal
data of the 8 billion
perspectives as the unity consciousness
the god consciousness if you will
and that that being the 99 that we
share genetically with each other as
humans
right and then on the individuation the
derivative level
it's the point one percent genetic
difference we have with each other
which is the unique gift or the unique
fruit or that
star that we're trying to bring to the
world our own unique
artistic painting or melody we're
playing or instrument in the big
symphony which is the integral and so if
we begin
also telling stories this way
right you take concepts from fields like
mathematics and you marry them with
spirituality and you tell them in an
explain like i'm five
story to people that makes them more
mindful
that makes them more loving makes them
more compassionate makes them more
artistic
i you know as you were speaking i was uh
reflecting back on that was a very
important moment in my life i was
working with the nonprofit foundation
helping to preserve orangutan i learned
that fact about the orangutan
and i really wrestled and tried to
understand like why
is it that we're so fundamentally wired
to focus on the differences
rather than the similarities and i
believe it's something from our prayer
mortal brain that carl sagan
identified in dragons for of eden where
it's the fear factor where you're out in
the wilderness you're crow magnet man
you don't understand
you're the fear is what's feeding your
decision-making and so you're looking
for differences
as a way to drive those decisions to
protect yourself
and i think the fundamental change we
need to make as a species in humanity
is and we're on the precipice with
technology that can destroy us
or take us forward to a whole new level
is how our perspective we can work on
like when gandhi said
you be the change you want to see in the
world
if we can start tapping in more to faith
rather than
fear yeah and faith based on reason
based on science based on spirituality
based on emotion based on intellect
all those eq iq sq
factors it's a tall order
but you know i i think if we get away
from looking at the
differences but start focusing again on
the commonalities
that will allow us to ultimately fulfill
what i believe god's purpose is for us
here to learn to grow and to graduate
yep now
one of the things that i think would be
potentially helpful to
to illustrate
is that when it we
are talking about and we have this
beautiful over-the-shoulder shot which
we'll be using boom
so when we talk about systematizing
genius when we talk about this sort of
love for
for patterns something that's
interesting that really i think we can
probably both
visually be able to agree on that may be
able to help the audience
as well kind of grasp this is something
along the lines of
there are
we can imagine just like cells we have
these eight billion
humans and that these eight billion
humans are
in pursuit of their north stars
and that all of them are sort of they
have different north star some of them
again are gonna find that bioengineering
one
some of them are gonna follow the
blockchain one some of them are just
gonna be artists
some of them are just gonna be good
parents
right so there's all different type
types of someone wants to be a
fortune 500 ceo right there's so many
different variations this can be thought
of as a big color wheel
along the along the pursuit and then
along
this journey of the
of the individuals that they
they have a power law
distribution
of what is actually located
right here
so what is located in this area
and so in that area we hypothesize
is the percent
of data or information
that they need to know
that's gonna actualize eighty percent of
their star
and so what we want to do is we want to
in a sense and let's see if you
agree with this we want to basically
catalyze for
all for all
8 billion people on the
and we can leverage artificial general
intelligence and we can leverage a lot
of the other pattern recognition
technologies that exist to assist us
with this process
but we want to maximize everyone's
ability
to rocket themselves over time
towards their stars and so that's
in essence the idea and we can leverage
that you know that agi
right we talked about this in chapter
six called ai coach
but would you say this is generally the
the sort of
idea of trying to identify the patterns
that people
are most in need for to achieve their
goals and to help
whether it's iq eq sq
well i i might look at it from a
slightly different direction you want to
draw
i'm sorry do you want to draw are you no
no i'm okay
i also was noticing very interesting
that you used red
and blue markers on a white canvas which
to me symbolizes freedom um
and people need that freedom to be able
to explore and to be able to accomplish
these
these things but um you know i would
just simply say that
yeah how do you see it consistently
you know pay attention to your
challenges and what keeps coming up
because it's probably your your
opportunities and
in both in areas that you're frustrated
in where
areas that you're accelerating in and
what your journey is based on
understanding that more clearly that you
know you
i i found that when i was growing up
i was always attracted to the my biggest
challenges like i had a fear of heights
and as a result of that fear of heights
i decided to go skydiving
that's right you know and and so the
things that you fear the most
and they they hold you back if you don't
address them
and get on the horse when it's thrown
you and
that can take many forms uh people
for example when i mentioned
narcissistic
it's an overcompensation for fear
and and you know being called out
for a lot of reasons that you're an
imposter or
that you you know we we tend to have
these counterweights
in our life and so we overcompensate in
many different ways
and i just think it's important to be
honest intellectually honest with
yourself
so that you can fully manifest
the genius in you and the gifts that you
have
and you know so many ways and in so many
areas
the fact that you may be in the wrong
job right now or the wrong profession
if you're not getting satisfied
satisfaction from it and you feel like
you're
not in the zone is a great indication
that
that's not what you were meant to do and
you should be pursuing something else
and there's ways to get the information
to really ultimately show up
on this earth where you're serving
yourself and serving others in a way
that's fully in balance
and i don't know if that addresses the
point that you made but that's what it
brought up for me because
there's different systems there's
different ways to follow and find your
north star
but intuition is there because it's a
powerful mechanism
it's the subconscious filing cabinet
telling you you need to open this file
and really
address it read it look at it learn from
it
and then move past it
there is a knocking
that happens there's an intuition that
happens
there is a
many different ways that the north star
enters into people's lives
that it's discovered that it's unveiled
that there's different ways to perceive
like we drew in that graphic there's
different ways to perceive the
the need for the eight billion cells
of the organism of the planet to get the
titration
thanks to potentially things like the ai
coaches
where you can actually get the exact
styles of processes there's three
specific ones that i think are really
important to give people to their stars
there's one of them that is around
longevity which is basically
the process of taking a stream of
biometrics of the body
and then keeping a youthful 18 year old
homeostatic capacity through the rest of
your life
there's the enlightenment which is
taking these states of non-dual
consciousness
and attempting to systematize the
process of them being grounded inside of
the psyche of the individuals as they
become their north star artists
and that's the last one the last one is
to
enable the systematic process if the
person is interested in the field of
blockchain that they become aware of
andreas antonopoulos they become aware
of satoshi nakamoto they become aware of
italic butter and they become aware of
the people and their podcasts and their
lectures
and the different uh practices around
using the actual programming
of decentralized applications and this
is where
what tristan was showing us earlier
these are the types of
technologies that are the fundamental
step that's getting us to the point
where the sovereign
individual intuitively metaphysically
what have you becomes more and more
aware of that star but then they're
always looking they're always trying to
figure out
where do i go where do i look next who
do i talk to how do i parse for the
information that's going to
help me attain these these realizations
of non-duality or longevity or my north
star
and i i think you hit on the key word
because you kept saying it awareness
but the way to have greater awareness is
to take
less focus off yourself and as a result
you have you know nature of [ __ ] of
vacuum
you have an ability then to fill that
vacuum by no longer
focusing on yourself but everything
beyond yourself
including other people that we're in a
relationship with
and so by being able to do that
you enhance your awareness and i believe
if you're aspiring to be a genius
or you are a genius and want to enhance
your genius
enhancing your awareness feeds that goal
and so the way to do that is simply to
start thinking again as i
went back to a recognition of the
service mentality
yeah and that we're all in a
relationship with one another
but you you brilliantly stated a number
of the
avenues and approaches and the
techniques that can help people
with that of opportunity thank you
thank you yeah that first
yeah i i've been enjoying the
the process of assisting the flowering
of the unique aromas of the brilliant
guests that we have on the program and
it's been actually quite nice when the
guest
also is hitting over really kind tennis
balls over to me that
share that that their aroma is in a
sense becomes more and more
possible through the kind of the
interlocutor process that then can
slowly over time identify these concepts
try and visualize them prioritize them
in the
in the star position in that hierarchy
so that we can
do our best to actually hone in our
energy
on on that focus on that
just fun to slow down for a moment and
be playful
all right man we've already hit so much
i love it
all right let's i love how you said
getting to the 22nd century
nobody's talking about that right now
that's a great way to put it we're all
unfortunately victims of the present
and by being in the present you can't
have a sense of the future or planning
for it
and for me you know i i as a
relationship-oriented people look down
the chess board
and i'm not seeing a lot of great stuff
ahead and
the only way that we can make sure that
our children and grandchildren inherit
the future we want
is to be more aware
that we have to start thinking beyond
ourselves
or beyond our immediate needs and so
i think it's really important to see
that that connectivity
allows us to create a future that we
actually are in charge of
rather than feeling that we're reactive
we can be proactive but in a way
that is in balance and our politics
right now
is so course because everyone has their
own viewpoints on that
but it's like what gandhi again said be
the change you want to see in the world
what is the world that we want to see
and we're
ultimately still in charge of that
decision
although i feel like the door is closing
in many respects
and so again i think the solution is not
about focusing on whether we mine more
coal
or we have a you know a trillion dollar
environmental plan it's really about
how we can see each other as
in a relationship that we can inform
each other and respect each other and
respect each other's differences
but the still at the end of the day come
to a conclusion where we can work
together
that will allow us to realize the goal
that we all want
which is a thriving society
a healthy society and and
a self-actualized society where people
can get along yep
a lot of people in modernity don't hear
the 22nd century
meme that you're teaching us about right
now and
a lot of the indigenous around the
planet have a seventh generation
principle that they work with on a
regular basis
they don't make any decision until
they think how's this going to affect
one two three four five six seven
generations down the line and so
to have a synthesis between these sorts
of ideas
in indigeneity where there is that depth
of interconnectedness where you can't
just dump something
into the river because you know it's
part of the hydrological cycle
toxins that type of stuff and the same
thing regarding the
actual biodiversity of the forests that
we can't just go and take short-term
decisions on
destruction of them where you basically
have this style of thought process that
i'm in an interconnected relationship
where those forests and the
phytoplankton and the oceans are
providing me with my 20 000 inhales of
oxygen that i take every day
that kind of knowledge enables
the seventh generation principle to
become more
embodied on a civilizational level and
then the architectures go in place
that prevent the short-term thinking so
this is on a very like
there's several sort of layers here and
one of them
really is on a you know the 22nd century
macro
level and on a on a micro
on a more meso let's say meso level on
the human level
you have the self-actualization and the
self-realization
and that those two things they need to
be
prioritized at the same degree as we
realize that the individuals sort of
catalyze a lot of the
civilizational macro level success so
the more that that wisdom is grounded
within the individual
the more that the social fabric itself
becomes more actualized
and the same thing's true as the social
fabric affects the individual that's
within it
they play off of each other when you
have something like
modern left versus right dynamics in the
united states
you actually have a embedded growth
obligation
in both the republican and the
democratic party that has it has come to
such
an outs an astounding degree
of perpetual
polarization polarization polarization
to where
there is no more idea of a take the baby
out of the bath water well there's only
one way of thinking
if you want to believe that your way of
thinking is the only way of thinking
and that is the challenge but i remember
integral perspective right that integral
where you see that the other
party right now i see that we're stuck
in phase two and i mean by that is that
when i was in college i learned about
the socratic method
of reasoning which is you start with a
thesis
and then you have antithesis and that's
phase two we're stuck in antithesis
right now
without realizing the beauty that it's
only part of a process of getting to
synthesis
and and so that whole synthesis is the
ability again to see that
maybe that orangutan with 97
of our dna that three percent difference
that we're focusing on
you can flip the script but you have to
be aware
that that's what's needed to get beyond
the polarization
that's ultimately leading to the wrong
direction
and a crack up here of what
we all ultimately want and so we're
distracted
by our own ego and our own determination
to believe that we're right and there's
only one right way of thinking
and you know i think with more
sensitivity
to the multi-dimensional ways that we
can think about things
we have a shot to get back to what our
founders wanted for us
which was a republic if we can keep it
yep
and the perverse incentives have taken
root which is that
approximately 250 years ago we actually
had
a very smart way of identifying that
if we're gonna have somewhere around
somewhere around 3 000 or 6 000 people
that are actually representing
every single uh that are being
represented by a single person in
congress
and then you have that go up by over a
hundred
x to six hundred thousand plus people
that are being represented by every
person in congress
over the span of 250 years that we would
need somewhere around 8 000 people in
congress to be at that same ratio as
when it was founded
and so it's an absolute ridiculous
uh inability to
to reason the complex variables that in
the pattern that was in the past and the
pattern that is now
in the perverse incentives that exist in
the system
but beyond that is the unity beyond that
is the synthesis like you described
it's when we take the babies we drain
the bathwater we take the babies we
merge them together into that synthesis
whether it be indigenating modernity the
left and the right in the u.s
china in the u.s hollywood and silicon
valley
there's so many of these polls that can
be harmonized emerged physicalism and
spirituality
the more and more that we do that
process and we prioritize that process
and we prioritize
upgrading our consciousness upgrading
our awareness to these
non-dual states also to these gift
actualizing states the more we do that
process
everything else falls in because you
become a channel everything falls into
place because you become a channel
everything that you touch turns to gold
because you are christ consciousness
buddha consciousness lao tza confucius
you begin
channeling that through you to
everything you touch but you must
experience that oneness you must
experience that unity
that symphony that is unfolding for you
to become that
true channel of that state we're all
instruments
of the cosmos
of uh i mean we're here on the earth i
personally believe because there is
a a higher power that would like to see
the best for us
but we have free will and we have the
choice
and and so what we choose particularly
now in a very very
important time will ultimately determine
whether i believe the human species
itself is sort of god's petri dish
and and how will turn out in these
thousands of years where we've evolved
or devolved to this point
will ultimately tell the story our story
and so there's a huge amount of really
important things riding on it and we now
have the technology to destroy ourselves
or as i said to improve ourselves
but by retaining sight of the bigger
picture here
uh and letting go of some of our ego
around all of these various issues
to strike common cause and common person
purpose
i believe it's it's almost a test right
now we're at a point in our
history where we can step off this
planet
and and not too many years from now
start colonizing others
yep but if we can't get along down here
what are we going to be doing out there
what are we exporting here we have to
solve it
now because otherwise it's like a virus
you know we we will be spreading beyond
where we are
and if we're a good and healthy
functioning system
that will take what we've realized
beyond and contribute
wherever and whatever that is that lies
beyond here
but if we can't we're just basically an
infection
and it's sad to think about it that way
but you know i i really believe that
it's a test
and right now we're not doing well
enough because we're too self-conscious
we're too ego driven we're too
dug in and by loosening that up i think
that is going to be our best destiny
yeah and on a metaphysical level
the god's petri dish analogy is strong
and i would also my take on it
as well is that we are publishers and
players of the game
so the kingdom of god is within you as
leo tolstoy said or tatsvamasi you
are that from the sanskrit spiritual
traditions or wahada al-wujud which is
the unity of all being existence from
the sufi traditions or i and my father
are one from
the new testament john 10 30. so over
and over again
the same mystic mystical wisdoms have
been communicated on the planetary level
and today we have
the virtual reality which is acting as
an awakening mechanism in many ways
to where consciousness begins to be able
to investigate itself because it learns
that
huh as i enter into these
indistinguishable three-dimensional
virtual worlds what's occurring is that
i have
forgotten about my three-dimensional
virtual world that i came from
and so it's this recursive process that
we're undergoing as we explore infinity
consciousness exploring infinity is my
current metaphysics
and that you can't ever finish exploring
an unbounded territory an unbounded map
there's no way to finish exploring it
and so it's just this
ongoing eternal cyclical cosmology of
consciousness exploring different
vehicles
and different phenomenologies that exist
and that these four limb two-eyed
carbon-based dna encoded creatures may
just be chocolate in the ice cream store
and then next is vanilla and mango and
cookies and cream and all these other
flavors to go and experience
and that if that is the nature of
reality
it's important to care it's important to
care about
this cycle it's important to care about
wanting to
help other people realize the nature of
consciousness the nature of reality
ground that in their being
and then be able to achieve get past the
fermi filters get to the godhead
go into the next potentially cycles of
consciousness exploring
i couldn't have said it better myself
interesting but no i think you you
stated that
very well and um
you know it's interesting we started
here about uh
systems and sequencing but ultimately
the greatest system and sequence that we
can uncover
is ourselves and the ability to master
that
system and that sequence will determine
our fate
and i hope we find it soon
but in the meantime uh you know as
i shared if uh there's people i can
impact with
some of the insights i've learned then
that is really part of my passion and
purpose and i'm
feeling like i'm doing what i can to
contribute to that whole process
yeah i couldn't have said that last part
better myself either
and this is the cool thing is that
neil has a mastermind and so you guys
can
if you'd like you can find the link in
the bio below i'll give you a little
give you a little little look at what
we're talking about
so you can find neil's website
worldclassconnections.com
the links in the bio below there's a
bunch of really cool information on
there
one of the talks that i watched neil
give was
it was over an hour it was the one that
neil was talking about where
afterward he was approached by dozens of
people to to schedule these
these masterminds that that he did with
them these private sessions coaching
sessions
and he really uh basically unpacks what
patterns
are in the world and what they what
analyzing them can do for systematizing
your own genius pursuit towards
your self-actualization and so again
there's
the links in the bio below check out his
website also check out the
the private coaching offering and the
mastermind i think neil and i
and potentially tristan and many others
in our nodal cluster are
going to be undergoing a process where
we ourselves
are going to be taking on more and more
of what
we're thinking about at these highest
levels and trying to disseminate them in
a more private setting to people that
want to join in
on that level and so i look forward to
seeing
you know what evolves from that and so
again do support
neil also support simulation our show
you can find our links in the bio below
you can
support the other artists entrepreneurs
the engineers the spiritual leaders
scientists in your communities around
the world support them help them
flourish um i have a funny silly
question
on the way out please i love these what
is your favorite food
my favorite food well i'm a misfit
i have a lot of different favorite foods
um growing up i can tell the joke
that i like to share with people that i
studied under one of the most popular
chefs
in america chef boyardee
and and yet i've had some of the finest
gourmet italian food since
and everything in between has tasted
pretty good i uh
i'm just grateful to have food i mean
literally because you know it feeds your
soul your spirit your psyche so
literally i
i'm an eclectic i i just like everything
yeah
and maybe that might not be a
satisfactory that's a good answer but
it's a truthful one
how about favorite foreign food favorite
foreign food
my favorite foreign food you know again
i i love italian i love middle eastern
food
uh i i love faux yeah
vietnam yeah right for sure um
everything's an experience and it's a
different part of the palette
and i guess i just embrace the richness
of
so many things that we're gifted to have
while we're here on the earth
yeah i agree i have that same style of
um uh a b
being a xenophile i love foreign
cultures yeah
and also especially the food but i'll
never forget
now from now on is the chef boyardee
joke
that's ridiculous oh my gosh okay that
was too funny
all right guys that's pretty much it we
love you very much thanks for tuning in
do you feel like we got pretty much
everything else i really enjoyed it i
thank you for this time yeah thank you
very much thank you too neil yeah this
was so special this is so so
special let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode subscribe
like the video share it with other
people let's systematize genius on a
planetary level everyone deserves to
actualize their gifts everyone deserves
to be self-realized self-actualized
let's make it to that recursive godhead
we love you very much thanks for tuning
in we will see you
soon much love everyone
peace